check out our sponsors Nature's Blends
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code truth 10 for 10%
of their
products brothers and sisters and dear
friends AMU I've been avoiding doing
this video just didn't want to the
hassle that he has you know a certain
following base uh that follow him and I
didn't want to get into it you know he
might have mean this or mean that there
was a video that I saw which I'm going
to show you guys in a minute inah and I
was trying to avoid it but you know what
I thought to myself this whole Palestine
issue we're all uniting we don't want to
talk about this stuff yeah but I saw
another video and I thought to myself
enough is enough now check this out guys
I want you really guys to understand
what is going on with these individuals
this Scholars M where you want to call
them people that certain individuals
follow whoever they follow for that
matter they do good works but they ruin
it with some stuff that they say see and
I wonder why do they say such stuff I
mean when I saw this I was thinking what
the hell is you on about those
extremists you don't want to share if I
came to your house ham Yu I don't know
where you live and then I occupied it
and took over cut the long story short
blah blah blah and I said yeah those
extremists you Hamza Yu they don't want
to share he doesn't want to share I've
kicked him out his whole house he lives
in a shed but he doesn't want to share
for the Muslims it's a red line for us
yeah it's as simple as that building the
uh the the temple that they went to
build over our dead bodies it's as
simple as that okay for you to call
individuals extremists who are going
through the suffering that they've been
going through for the past 75 plus years
it's very very it just questions and
begs your Humanity like for you to so
casually say these extremist they just
don't want to share there's enough space
I really wonder what is going through
your mind now let's go to this second
video which is it just really blows your
mind I want you guys to watch this with
me inshallah and tell me that this
doesn't boil your blood let's watch for
ourselves we have to recognize that it's
not reasonable to think that the unjust
being unjust will lend an ear to our
please for justice so if the principle
is sound the question becomes one of
means sometimes it's absolutely
necessary to suffer in
silence sometimes it's that's the means
of survival you cannot make this up yeah
and brothers and sisters if you look
like I've done a little bit of research
speaking to some brothers there is some
pack that Hamza Yu and his teacher and a
few others have signed I don't want to
go into details but it seems like
there's a cross breed happening of the m
and certain sufis which is that you do
not rebel against the government at all
cost now I believe in this Principle as
well yes I believe in this Principle as
well however to say that at any cost or
any shape or form that there is no
certain legislation in place that you
can Rebel depend on conditions and I
believe the harm is greater than the uh
the good but the point is what that they
are going to levels of basically telling
the Palestinians that you should suffer
in silence I want to ask a question to
ham youf why did you you not suffer in
silence instead of making that statement
if it really was an itch for you and you
had to say why did you not suffer in
silence but no you had to say it why CU
you believe it's the right thing to do
very bizarrely but very interestingly
look what happens next of survival but
it doesn't mean it's
final respect to our
dear
okay
if they us to leave the
building so somebody pulled alarm Bell
and also people were angry and enraged
of the comments that he made it is very
easy I would have expected this from
Farris hamadi who's on the payroll yeah
I would have expected this from him yeah
him laughing about the issue and
giggling and laughing Etc but no now
we're seeing individuals like Hamza Yu
clearly outright outright saying that
them suffer in silence it's well and
good for you my friend it is so well
good and good for you the one whose
stomach is full will never understand
the one that's hungry if your children
were being slaughtered and massacred and
if you had the Glimpse 10% or 1% of what
the Palestinians are going with their
resilience their resistance if you went
through that and if somebody came to you
and said Hamza y your family members
have been killed your wife has been
abducted and God knows what else they've
done yeah and and yourself you are here
about to die suffer in silence sometimes
you have to suffer in silence what would
you say it's easy and this is what I
hate about the hypocrisy of individuals
put yourself in the shoes of these
Palestinians and from the information
that I have I'm going to put a website
brother sister you can check in the
description below the Muslim Elders it
seems that there has been a pact made
with h his seniors yes and a group of
individuals tied to a specific country I
don't want to get into details cuz I can
get in trouble yeah I'm not going to get
into details that this p is very simply
and clearly seen at any cost wherever it
is they are against any kind of
protesting or Rebellion be it the wiers
in China be it the syrians in Syria be
it the Palestinians in Palestine so much
so that I heard ham Yu is even against
the black lives matter movement in
America that's that's how deep it goes
and even with the disbelievers he has at
policy we will not let anybody for that
matter if it's myself if it's someone
like ham Yu I don't care who the hell
you are with a Palestine issue you are
not going to so boldly come forward and
say
sometimes you have to suffer in silence
no because the biggest form of Injustice
in this D is to associate Partners to
Allah and that is something that we
should be striving to do against our own
souls and the greatest form of Justice
ised to worship Allah and sing him out
in his worship and airm his attributes
for himself that is the biggest form of
justice and Islam's principles is upon
Justice Allah says in the Quran let
there Rise amongst you a group of people
who will enjoy good with evil and speak
the truth even if this against yourself
or your kin and Allah subhana says in
the
Quran come together with righteousness
so saw the prophet peace was in a pact
that was made against a man who was
oppressed he and the prophet PE him said
if I was to if this situation happened
at this time I would have joined that
pack again meaning what the worst of the
most mus he went and joined them why
because a person was oppressed one
person was oppressed because he was not
paid his money that was ow to him what
do you think the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him would have done if he saw
what the Palestinians are going through
if he saw what the holy lands going
through do you think he would have gone
and tell these people suffer in silence
never he would so what I'm going to say
respectfully you are older than me
senior than me I'm just going to say in
a few words it is very disappointing
very very disappointing to hear someone
like yourself who you can look at me and
say a YouTuber a clickbait artist
whatever you want to call it a j no
problem I don't mind those Ali needs da
yes that's correct I am going to call
out anyone for that matter they will not
suffer in silence and neither will we
allow those who say suffer in silence to
say what they're saying and get Scot
free no you will be held to account from
your ticktockers to your FIS hammis to
Hamza Yu we don't care who you are the
Palestinians will not will not give up
after what they've been through for many
years centuries they will not and they
are the most resilient we look up to
them yes we get our energy alhamd
looking at them and we admire them
they're resilient let it continue and
brothers and sisters carry on the
boycott fix your relationship with Allah
subhana number one give Allah's rights
yes Allah's rights come before any human
beings that's been oppressed number two
carry on the boycott number three share
those posts don't stop number four uh
brother sisters inshallah make Dua for
the brothers and sisters in Palestine
that's all I'm going to say inshallah
and I thank those who were in the crowd
who called him out and caused him to
leave and especially the individual who
pulled the alarm may Allah bless you
inshallah enjoyed good and forbid evil
you saw evil and you stopped it with
your hand by pulling the alarm Bell and
then there was those who spoke out
against it and then there was those in
the crowd who may have hated in their
heart but they did not verbally say it
till next
time check out our sponsors Nature's
Blend they specialize in premium
Ethiopian black seed products the
website is in the descript destion link
below you can also use the discount code
truth 10 for 10% of their products